qué es un capacitor esto es un capacitor
y bueno que haya dentro de esto lo que
hay adentro de este capacitor es
básicamente lo mismo que hay adentro de
todos los capacitores dos pedazos de
material conductor como el metal que
están separados entre sí estos pedazos
de papel están aquí para asegurarse que
las dos piezas de metal no se toquen
entre sí pero esto para qué nos sirve
bueno si conectamos dos pedazos de metal
a una batería esos pedazos de metal
pueden almacenar carga y para eso nos
sirven los capacitores los capacitores
almacenan carga una vez que se conecta
la batería las cargas negativas del lado
derecho son atraídas a la terminal
positiva de la batería y en el lado
izquierdo las cargas negativas son
repelidas por la terminal negativa de la
batería conforme las cargas dejan el
lado derecho del metal dejan al metal
del lado derecho este pedazo de metal se
va a volver positivo en su carga ya que
ahora este pedazo de metal va a tener
menos negativos que positivos y el
pedazo de metal a la izquierda va a
tener cada vez más carga negativa porque
tiene más negativos que positivos es
importante notar que ambas piezas de
metal van a tener la misma cantidad o
magnitud de carga en otras palabras si
la carga del pedazo de metal a la
derecha es de 6 culo es positivo
entonces la carga del metal que está a
la izquierda va a ser de menos 6 colores
ya que por cada carga negativa que fue
quitada del metal del lado derecho
tendremos que exactamente una carga
negativa va a ser depositada en el metal
del lado izquierdo aún cuando las dos
piezas de metal sean de diferente tamaño
o incluso de forma ambas van a guardar
la misma cantidad pero con diferente
signo de carga ahora solo he mostrado a
las cargas negativas en movimiento ya
que en la realidad los electrones que
tienen carga negativa son los que se
mueven con libertad
de un metal un material conductor los
protones con carga positiva
prácticamente se quedan en su lugar este
proceso de carga intercambiando los
lados no va a continuar para siempre las
cargas negativas del lado derecho serán
atraídas a la terminal positiva de la
batería pero llegará un momento en la
que estas cargas también serán atraídas
por la carga positiva de este pedazo de
metal y eventualmente las cargas
negativas se verán más atraídas hacia
las cargas positivas en el pedazo de
metal y de igual manera que se sienten
atraídas hacia la terminal positiva de
la batería una vez que esto ocurre el
proceso se detiene y la carga acumulada
se queda en el pedazo de metal podemos
quitar la batería y la carga se va a
mantener igual en cada pedazo de metal
las cargas negativas van a querer
regresar con las cargas positivas porque
los opuestos se atraen pero no hay una
ruta en donde puedan llegar a ellas esto
también explica por qué los pedazos de
metal tienen que estar separados entre
sí si lo
pedazos de metal se tocaran durante este
proceso entonces ninguna carga se va a
separar los negativos van a estar
recorriendo el circuito ya que tenemos
un circuito cerrado y es por eso que
queremos el papel entre los dos pedazos
de metal para evitar que estos pedazos
de metal se toquen así que los
capacitores son dispositivos usados para
almacenar carga y no todos los
capacitores van a almacenar la misma
cantidad de carga un capacitor conectado
a una batería puede almacenar mucha
cantidad de carga pero otro capacitor
conectado a la misma batería no va a
almacenar la misma cantidad de carga la
capacitancia de un capacitor es el
número que nos dice que tan bueno es
este capacitor para guardar carga un
capacitor con una capacitancia grande
almacenará mucha carga y un capacitor
con una capacitancia pequeña pues va a
almacenar menos carga la definición de
capacitancia se resume con esta fórmula
la capacitancia es igual a la cantidad
de carga almacenada
entre el voltaje que pasa a través de
ese capacitor aun cuando técnicamente la
carga neta en un capacitor sea de cero
porque almacena la misma cantidad de
carga negativa que de carga positiva la
q en esta fórmula se refiere a la
magnitud de la carga en uno de los lados
del capacitor y al voltaje al que nos
referimos en esta fórmula se refiere al
hecho de que cuando un capacitor
almacena carga va a crear un voltaje o
una diferencia de potencial eléctrico
entre los dos pedazos de metal el
potencial eléctrico es alto en la región
de las cargas positivas y la energía
potencial es menor en la región de las
cargas negativas así que si tenemos
cargas positivas que se encuentran
cercadas pero no dentro de una región de
cargas negativas vamos a tener una
diferencia en el potencial eléctrico en
esa región y a esto le llamamos voltaje
es útil saber que si dejamos que una
batería cargue por completo un capacitor
es el voltaje a través de ese capacitor
va a ser el mismo que el de la batería
bien a la fórmula de capacitancia
veremos que las unidades van a ser cool
oms sobre volt un color por bolt es un
far as of a radio y esto es en honor de
el físico inglés michael faraday así que
si permitimos que una batería de 9
voltios cargue completamente un
capacitor de 3 para la carga almacenada
va a ser de 27 culos en otro ejemplo si
tenemos que un capacitor de 2 farts
almacena una carga de 6 q los podremos
usar esta fórmula para encontrar el
voltaje a través de este capacitor o la
caída de voltaje que en este caso es de
3 volts y ustedes pueden pensar que
mientras más cargas se almacenen un
capacitor la capacitancia debe aumentar
pero esto no sucede así el valor de la
capacitancia permanece igual y conforme
aumenta la carga el voltaje a través de
este capacitor también aumenta lo que
hace que la proporción se mantenga igual
la única
manera de cambiar la capacitancia de un
capacitor es alterar las características
físicas de ese capacitor como el hacer
que sean más grandes las piezas de metal
o hacer que se separen más las piezas de
metal pero solo cambiar la carga o el
voltaje no nos va a cambiar la
proporción que representa la
capacitancia
ah